all over the world farmers who have
fields on hillsides have to struggle
with water erosion they clear trees to
gain space so they can plant crops and
graze livestock but with the tree roots
gone there is nothing to keep the rain
from washing the topsoil away the
topsoil is the most fertile layer this
process is already far advanced on
Myanmar's inland lake the farmers on the
hillside above are losing arable land
and the lake is silting up when the
water level is low many of the famous
stilt houses can hardly be reached and
the lake dwellers are steadily losing
their primary food source the native
fish can't live in the muddy waters
several initiatives have been started on
site to counter this development one
solution is to plant fast-growing trees
among the crops another is to build
terraces and small dams to hold the soil
on the hillside fields erosion can also
be a problem on more or less flat ground
if the fields are wide and there are no
hedges or trees the fertile topsoil will
soon be gone with the wind Georgia like
many other Eastern Bloc countries has to
contend with the legacy of Soviet
collective agriculture
cropland stretches away to the horizon
and winds often reach speeds of up to 60
kilometres an hour the deeper the soil
is plowed the faster the nutrients in
the soil are depleted new kinds of
machines can help they keep soil
disruption to a minimum trees can be
planted along the fields edges as wind
breaks
the world population is growing and with
it the demand for food more and more
forests will be cleared for farming this
problem is especially acute in tropical
latitudes the rain forest floor is poor
in nutrients but rich in oxygen that
makes it unsuitable for industrial
agriculture Columbia has cleared
thousands of square kilometres of
rainforest to make way for palm oil
plantations palm oil may be healthy and
useful for refining cosmetics or making
biofuels but once the soil is depleted
by the palm tree monocultures the
planters move on and clear more land but
there is another way
ecological farmers plant many different
crops in the same ground to help balance
out soil use all kinds of plants can
grow in between the palm trees
fertilizer can be made from byproducts
of the plantations own production that
eliminates the need to clear new land
and helps preserve the forest and its
biodiversity
only a farmers care for the land they've
got will there be a future for both man
and beast